all right um if you have already you can
draw this now this is actually a
particular question from the exercise
I'm going to use it as my opportunity to
for my neighbor how this works
and particularly everyone here and point
out something new now you don't have
Simpsons rule rather you're gonna
perform in a dodgy way does anyone
remember for Simpsons rule what is the
approximate area H over 3 and then
you've got this thing okay you got the
first one you got sorry that should be
anyway what did I say this do you since
I still have my letters all mixed up
it's the first distance and then it's
the middle distance and then it's bad
I'll yeah and like I said I didn't think
the letters okay now when you have a
look at this
if you then as always with a formula
like I equals P RN or FB equals P V blah
blah blah you've got to think about how
to use it okay the first thing that's a
bit weird to me is unexpected this
number to be these guys because they're
all the same
okay they're all the heights but they're
not expecting three other numbers and I
had a full practice so you kind of
scratch your head now I kind of alluded
to this the first time I showed you I
said if you want you to be more accurate
instead of looking at three values you
just take more measurements more
measurements will give you more accuracy
right so I'm going to use another color
and I want you to notice if I want three
values I have a look at these three one
two three
if I pop them into the formula that will
tell me in this area do you agree do you
see how it caps off that top huh
then I have to do with the bottom half
and I need another three numbers three
different numbers okay we'll have a look
when you go down here
you have to reuse the 33 that's fine it
becomes your new first one then the last
one you use 40 that'll be your middle
one and then what happens here
well when you if you remember when we
did what support again or when we went
out to the field I feel diagrams right
one of these will keep us and another
person is walking away at measuring
right well how far away is the person
gonna walk there's no answer
they're not gonna walk away from you at
all right so your third number down here
when you drew this all over again is so
now you can see one two three four the
firsts application one two three what a
second up does that make sense what
actually do it just so you can confirm
you know you're doing it right I'm going
to say therefore the area is
approximately equals two and I have to
use the same thing twice okay so you
come to the first one sixteen on three
Oriana 41 for those there's the top part
right so there's the area that I've used
up there first middle plus and then I
have to start all over again for the
blank area down there sixteen on it
still a top three you know is now first
for the middle and lost see how I did it
and then the rest of industro becomes a
bit of number crunching for your
calculator does someone
alright who's that yep 1637 appointments
for carrying three unless I did it wrong
can we have some confirmation does that
look right someone else go they
calculate a minute